There is freedom in responsibility,
you know, and that earn your way there.
We remember the stuff we earn, the stuff
we experience more than what the teacher
tells us or what someone gives us for
free. We just do. We broke a proverbial
sweat on it. Whether it's mental or
physical or whatever, we we we built it.
We we understand. We felt how we got it,
how we achieved it, how we got what we
wanted. Those stick with us whether we
forget them intellectually. They were
written in our lineage and they build
resilience and they and and and they
build a healthy true optimism going
forward to know that oh no I've I've
I've worked for something before and
achieved It.